tous les quinze jours le trap blog
organise cette conférence de rédaction
mac en écrit pour le blog depuis sa
création en octobre dernier
alors aujourd'hui c'est l'occasion de
donner des conseils aux nouveaux
rédacteurs peut-être de futurs reporter
des quartiers comme il se définit
lui-même le trapu boxer pour moi être
comme une sorte d' apprenti journaliste
du quartier en fête et de donner la
parole de parler de sujets qu'on abatte
pas forcément dans les grands journaux
et donner la parole aux gens du quartier
aux jeunes du quartier
en tout cas moi c'est ce que je fais et
c'est ce que j'ai compris du temple bloc
la voilà c'est l'avant dernier j'avais
écrit sur nu debout à l'arrière
passionné de foot et de rap mac ans
s'intéresse désormais à tout sujet nuit
debout le ramadan ou encore l'insécurité
de son quartier du bois de l'étang à la
verrière semedi fondateur du blog qui le
pousse à exprimer de nouvelles idées je
suis pas là pour proposer comme si en
fait il était salarié ou quoi que ce
soit l'idée là c'est vraiment devoir en
fait quels sont leurs envies est ce que
moi je pense être
une bonne idée et en fait vraiment dans
le partage et les changes sur ces
thématiques ou sur ces problématiques là
qu'on arrive à créer quelque chose de
nouveau et souvent d'inattendu et qui
correspond en fait plus à leur style
âgés de 16 à 30 ans ils sont désormais
15 à collaborer autre api blog autant de
profils différents qui montre la
diversité des parcours en banlieue